I
hi I'm Chad Armstrong senior designer at
Crystal Dynamics and I'd like to talk to
you guys about our interactive
broadcasting first thing I'd like to
talk about is card voting we have a card
system that is used in our expedition
mode such as score attack and chapter
replay and spectators on twitch are able
to vote for cards that are activated in
the middle of a game play session these
cards remain active until five minutes
pass or the player dies or a checkpoint
is reloaded many of our cards are meant
to be advantageous while some are
challenging and others are just meant to
be entertaining the big head mode card
for example is pretty self-explanatory
another example is rainbow trail like
the card suggests laura has a rainbow
trout behind her because why not another
example is time quake time quake creates
a bubble of slowed time around an enemy
who's killed with a headshot using a bow
this time allows you to line up your
next shot or move in close and deliver a
melee kill to whoever's left it's worth
pointing out that you don't actually
have to have these cards in your
inventory in order for them to activate
the uncorked card also has a special
effect when you score a head shot with
uncorked active a head shot creates a
colorful and powerful explosion that
takes out other nearby enemies the guest
trap card has a chance of creating a
poisonous cloud around an enemy you kill
this cloud will devastate any other
nearby enemies and is great for clearing
out groups at once something else you
might have noticed throughout the video
is the title bar across the top and
bottom of the screen we call that the
broadcast frame the broadcast frame can
be turned on at any time and can be used
to allow your spectators to get an idea
as to where you are in the game and what
kind of progress you've made it shows
things such as how far you traveled how
many enemies you've killed and how many
collectibles you've found
that covers it thank you for watching
and we look forward to having you guys
play rise of the Tomb Raider November
10th
you